frau hardcase machen sie sich auch
sorgen um die gastro vielfalt glauben
sie dass die ausstirbt tatsächlich ja
wir haben ja schon riesige probleme
wären insgesamt seit pandemie begehen
neun monate im lockdown wir sind seit
anfang november mit einer
stornierungswelle ohnegleichen
konfrontiert und das schlimmste ist dass
wir bis september schon 94 1000
beschäftigte verloren haben gegenüber
2009 10 und es muss da ganz ganz
dringend und appelliere ich jetzt
wirklich an die bundesregierung ja das
erhöhte kurzarbeitergeld fortgeführt
werden es kann nicht sein dass
mitarbeiter die schon mal sechs monate
jetzt während der pandemie zeit in
kurzarbeit waren 80 prozent cook
bekommen haben dass die ab januar auf 60
prozent zurückfallen dann verlieren wir
noch mal 100.000 mitarbeiter und das ist
jetzt aktuell meine allergrößte sorge
natürlich kommt es auch darauf an dass
die unternehmen einen schadensausgleich
bekommen ja dass sie ausreichende
unterstützung erfahren weil es ist
einfach im moment richtig richtig heftig
und wir müssen da durchkommen es kann
nicht sein dass wir aufgrund des
missmanagements in sachen impfen ja
heute wieder da sind was jeder politiker
ausschließen wollte alle haben sie
gesagt es gibt keinen lockdown mehr es
gibt zumindest keinen lockdown mehr für
geimpfte und jetzt haben wir den salat
und ich erwarte von den
landesregierungen dass die
praxistaugliche verhältnismäßige
regelungen schaffen und 2g plus ist
keine also zweig ja aber ansonsten lohnt
es sich wirklich nicht mit 2g plus zu
arbeiten übrigens noch ein schmankerl
heute hat niedersachsen unter anderem
entschieden dass diejenigen die
geburtstags sind die benötigen jetzt
keinen test mehr also eine weitere
variante und in berlin heißt der zweige
plus kämpft genesen und mit maske ins
restaurant bis zum platz und danach
alles wieder abziehen eigentlich ist ja
ja schwierig muss man sagen dass ja sehr
jung unterschiedene bessere lösung als
zweig plus also weil eben auch gar keine
test kapazitäten da sind das ist ja
alles runter gefahren und überall sehen
sie die schlangen vor den testzentren
für den impfzentren es ist einfach
deprimierend und hier muss jetzt
schnellstmöglich maximal professionell
agiert werden